I'm going to propose that we have to
take measures which must be European
measures we don't expect to have
national measures because this is a
European problem and those measures have
to consider as well that the diesel
engine industry here in Europe is a key
industry user forum I think we won't be
in following events over the last few
days member states are doing everything
they can to try and clarify the
situation Germany has said it will give
its full support to our attempts to
manage the situation we all agree that
we need to provide consumers and the
entire sector with confidence that this
sector should enjoy we must not be
excessively negative we have to firstly
establish facts in a European in all
European member states as soon as
possible the second step is to finalize
the real driving emission tests quickly
new test has to be ambitious has to be
robust we have to of course reassess our
proposal in light of this false wagon
case that we have now we will analyze
everything will have notables the
European unitary patent we are very
close to conclude the process that has
lasted for the last 40 years so I will
welcome Italy the 26th member of the
state to join the pattern